Oh, hello!
It's time for Nailed It!
The show that's looking for this...
but ends up finding this.
Put on your brave face and start...
baking!
-Bake! What is wrong with you?
-Go, go, go, go!
-Oh.
-Oh, no!
What happened?
If I die because you stapled something
to food...
I'm doing it with my hands.
Why are you on the floor?
What are you doing?
-Oh, God.
-Am I the only one that's lost?
-No.
-I've never made anything like this.
I can't do it. I give up.
Let's see your Marvel cupcake
and cookie toppers!
-Is there an apple in there? Really?
-I'd eat it.
Nailed it!
That's what I was going for.
No! It's not that bad.
It was like pulling a piece of pineapple
out the trash and putting it in my mouth.
-Oh!
-Oh, no! Marie Antoinette again!
Oh, no!